every great fighter needs a good  nickname yep now i got to start knocking  people out though so that they can start  saying time to sleep put them to sleep  in the sand  frankie moves everything at the same  time body's moving  oh my god  i mean we've been working a lot me and  christian uh my coach i mean we've been  working a ton on like hey man i want to  start putting guys away you know like i  got point people blah blah blah but like  i want to start putting people away i  mean you're becoming uh a knockout  artist  because i swear the vision big just like  the thick boys squad  big boy squad big boy nation big boy  squad  [Music]  running out of big